this film was born in the state of North
Carolina as it were and that's because
that's where you Nancy and you Colin
first met can you explain how this
relationship between the two of you
started and what the mutual interest was
in this story yes I can I was under way
with the documentary I discovered
Mildred story by reading her obituary
and I was struck with the power of the
story and the fact that I didn't know
anything about Mildred and Richard
loving and I felt like that was a huge
oversight I started working on the
documentary I met Colin's wife and told
her about it and she said you know Colin
would be really interested in this it
was just a couple months later that he
was shooting a film Main Street in
Durham North Carolina and a festival
that I used to run called the full-frame
documentary film festival was taking
place exactly at the same time and so we
all got together and I started telling
Colin about the story and I think he was
immediately taken with it and I guess
they say the rest is history right yeah
I mean I was just completely blown away
that such a gripping an important story
was seemed to be so unknown you know and
also that it was so unusual set against
the background of that decade and
everything was going on in the civil
rights movement actually right on the
doorstep and once these two people in
Washington you know there were a few
blocks away from the marches and Martin
Luther King's Speech and they had
absolutely no interest in it whatsoever
and so in the conventional sense they
were not activists and yet this
commitment to each other
proved to be so forceful an example of
how something so quiet can lead to
something so immense you know and a lot
more radical than it seems at first
glance because mmm they did have choices
if they divorced each other they
probably could have gone back and led
very much like the ones they've been
living before but that was
non-negotiable and so there's so many of
these elements I felt were a missing
piece of a very important missing piece
of the history of that time Jeff you've
made so many great films in the last
number of years like take shelter and
mud and Midnight Special
what made this one different in the fact
that this is a movie that didn't come
from your imagination this I think is
the first time that you've ever worked
on a film written a film that wasn't an
original story how did that change
things for you it's interesting the the
difference is though great honestly
don't feel that extreme when the work
starts you know in each of my films I
try and look for some emotional core
something that I feel that is palpable
the potential of death of my son and
Midnight Special high school heartbreak
in mud the end of the world and take
shelter these are things that that I
carry around with me and and I feel like
if I can build at least one moment in
the films that represents that that it
will somehow transfer over to the
audience in this case that scene exists
several of them but but it wasn't it
wasn't my story it was Richard in
Mildred's but despite that fact I still
felt this palpable connection to it I
felt a palpable connection to Mildred's
love of place especially the south
that's something I can identify with
greatly I think I think I I totally
empathize with Richard's inability to
take care of his family
despite
fact that that was the one thing he was
capable of doing these were these were
emotions that even to this day when I
watch them they just they sting and and
that's what I look for in a story but in
this particular instance I think there
was a great responsibility that came
with it
a responsibility to not over emphasize
her or or try to to glorify something
that wasn't there because what was there
was so beautiful and so sincere it
really didn't need any polishing I just
had to be true to it and and it would do
the heavy lifting I'm very excited to
address a question to Joel and Ruth just
so I can hear you all gasp when you hear
what the two of them actually sound like
in comparison to how they sound in the
movie is it harder to do less than it is
to do more well you know like to kind of
roll along with what Jeff's saying and
what's been spoken about already is that
what one of the great things about this
movie I think it's a Jeff chose and
these guys chose to take a true story
and and then trust Jeff to make it and
his his mattress seemed to be all the
way along the line not just to strive
for accuracy in in on all fronts but to
tell a true story truthfully this is
actually it sounds very simple but it's
very rare we'll watch movies in
Hollywood and go this is a true story
with a bit of extra stuff to make it an
experience in the cinema but but this
story was enough these people were
enough you fall in love with them and in
fact it's better that you tell the Tauri
story truthfully in order that you
really truly fall in love with them and
experience what they experience and have
an empathetic experience with them
Richard was a very is I think it was a
very intuitive person incredibly simple
in a wonderfully
human way and and not very vocal but yet
when you watch Nancy's documentary and
when you watch all of the extra archival
footage that she provided to Jeff that
couldn't go into the documentary yeah
you see a man who is thinking a lot and
saying very little and and in in the
matter of telling that to his story
truthfully Jeff stay true to that and it
was it definitely in terms of my
portrayal of him it was my task to to do
that and and and together you know the
three of us and but come in conversation
particularly with Jeff in regards to
Richard we're looking for the
specificity of the silence you know the
reasons for the silence rather than just
a man who sort of switched off to what
was going on around him I think he had a
very deeply emotional response to what
was going on deep levels of frustration
a constant search for the way out I
think unlike Mildred who was looking
forward and tiptoeing to look over the
fence and look into the horizon of what
was what was possible in the future
Richard seemed to be looking for a way
out of the view of the camera on him on
a micro level on a macro level a way out
of the whole situation and I wish to
make everybody else but Mildred
disappear I was so struck by the scene
where the the police officers show up
when you have your newborn in your hands
and the way that you play that is just
utterly devastating in its subtlety was
that a scene that was particularly
exciting or challenging for you to do um
it was it was particularly heartbreaking
because that happened you know and to
think this but I would have to do this
in order to sort of maintain some sort
of strange moment of peace it's really
extraordinary where there were many
moments throughout the civil rights
struggle
I think thus the thing is is that um
Nancy's documentary you know which has
features archival footage of this couple
was a real gift to us as actors it's
basically not seated all my homework for
me and Missy is a beautiful portrait on
this couple a study in this couple and
um it was really invaluable for us you
know from a physical practical point of
view from an you know an outside-in
point of view you know the way they
moved the way they talked the way they
spoke there most importantly the energy
between them which was really palpable
and tangible and beautiful and and and I
think that's what captivation people
when they see this couple on the screen
and that and that was what we that was
our challenge is to recreate that but we
felt very supported is the most one of
the most collaborative experiences you
know because there's a whole there's a
whole heap of us in it
not to mention mr. mr. Kenneth Walker
who um you know you know there's nothing
like seeing yourself transformed to
someone in front of a mirror that gives
you confidence and in your ability to
play that person you know in a very
basic visual but super important level
and I've truly credit mr. ken and Judith
Alice and Aaron Minocqua that Kenneth
what was most helpful for you and coming
up with the hairstyles I would imagine
the footage that Nancy unearthed for her
documentary and then I was thinking was
everything that exists of Richard and
Mildred in black and white or was there
any color photography any color footage
basically it was black and white but
Jeff was my leader of the pack and Ruth
and mr. Joel
they had definite opinions about it
and Nancy's computer Ruth's computer
opened up every morning when we started
a scene and we would go over these
hairstyles every day and it was just a
joy to come in there and have this peace
of knowing that this woman knew what she
had studied Mildred long before we even
started working this show Jeff when he
saw Joel's hair it was like really dark
and Richard was a blonde and we worked
and we worked and we toned and we
figured it out and it worked so well
after we discovered the formula that we
but just being on this show because when
I first got the call for this show Sarah
green called me and we were she was
telling me about loving us and you mean
the Lovings in Richmond Virginia because
believe it or not I lived around that
time and I knew the story and I was like
oh yeah I got to do this this is
something I must do
because it's a piece of history it's
what's going on right now the civil
rights and everything that was going on
and growing up in Los Angeles people
would never believe that I went through
some kind of horrendous things and I got
through that but to be a part of this
film and watch and figure out not just
for these two but we had a whole cast
that we had to work with and create a
whole visual for that period and the 50s
was marked down in my time and then we
went into the 60s and it was just a
joyous occasion it was a collaborative
thing we had wardrobe we had makeup and
we had chef who spoke his mind and I
followed the leader you know and it was
good well I can't thank all of you
enough for making this film in for being
with us tonight